is it very dangerous here
[Music]
the top 10 most dangerous cities in the
world are all in south and central
america and i visited most of them
this region is awash with drugs and guns
angry sap cry
and it keeps it doesn't stop
this is all about economics and trade
supply and demand and the biggest
demander is the united states just to
the north
the biggest consumer of illegal drugs in
the world is the united states
that demand fuels violence and
corruption across south and central
america
you've got the cartels and you've got
the very organized and competing crime
gangs across the region
but the key is always poverty and crime
and corruption feed off poverty
you have poor and badly run countries
with an abundant natural growth of
marijuana and poppy fields
this exploitation of the land and the
people by cartels militias and gangs
contributes to violent and corrupt
societies this is what we have to do
right now so
we can get
some money and because of the familial
political structure of gangs and
organized criminal groups where families
stay loyal to families and neighbours to
neighbours
entire communities are run by heavily
armed groups with weapons who oversee
the drugs trade on their doorsteps
this is the dividing line
and if you came out of this area and
crossed over there and they didn't know
you they'd kill you you can see over
there
there's 13 written on the wall
you have groups competing for territory
and murder rates are almost entirely
driven by revenge killings
using violence to settle differences is
the norm and they kill
with impunity
not only do you have gang on gang or
cartel on cartel violence but you also
have gangs and cartels fighting the
police who are trying to bring down
crime and murder rate
many low-level gang and cartel members
are very young men and high unemployment
rates across the continent contribute to
their life of crime
in brazil i met one drug gang operating
in a favela in rio de janeiro
the gang members i met were very very
young indeed early 20s at the most
i asked them why they were part of the
gang and they mostly answered the same
they can't get a job anywhere else
because of where they come from a pool
favela
that's like
okay
i was amazed when they said that they
did actually want to have other jobs
away from a life of crime they just
can't get any so they have to do this
job and they do see it as a job to feed
their families
[Music]
poverty corruption and the lucrative
drugs trade is in one way or another
connected to the high level of violence
on the continent
but worryingly organized crime gangs and
cartels are also branching out into
other areas like people smuggling and
let's not forget this continent is next
door to the united states the biggest
user of drugs and guns in the world
ironically it's also the place many
people escaping the violence are
actually trying to get to
you